welcome back to las vegas now many of us
are spring cleaning our closets so why
not our diets too
registered dietitian mia sin shares
simple ways to spring clean your diet so
that you feel your best as we head into
the warmer weather
take a look hey las vegas now happy
spring today i have four simple ways to
spring clean your diet
so that you feel your best this season
my first tip is to spring clean your
breakfast
by building it around protein and whole
grains toast is an easy way to do that
here i used the three new organic gluten
free loaves by little northern bakehouse
which are made with whole grains and
seeds
are allergy friendly and free from eggs
and dairy but
have the delicious taste and texture you
would want in bread you can find them in
the refrigerated section in most natural
grocery stores
for protein i added hummus crunchy
chickpeas and peanut butter
and my next tip is to spring clean your
snacks by building them around protein
produce and healthy dips these snack
boxes check
all of those boxes for the dips i'm
adding fresh cravings salsa and creamy
hummus which are nutrient dense dips
with a short list of high quality
whole food ingredients the new fresh
cravings hummus offers a balanced mix of
good fats
fiber and plant protein from chilean
extra virgin olive oil
non-gmo chickpeas and savory tahini find
both in the refrigerated section in the
produce department at smith's
my next tip is to spring clean your
meals by going plant-based
this zucchini noodle bolognese is made
with pea protein grounds by fry's who
makes award-winning frozen meat
alternatives that you can find at
sprouts
all of the fry's products including the
chicken nuggets the big fry burger
chicken patties and breakfast links are
good sources of plant protein
naturally cholesterol free and low in
saturated fat for busy weekdays my mega
head vegetarian burrito bowl is a great
option
add brown rice black beans corn sauteed
bell peppers and red onion
salsa and like meats plant-based like
chicken from sprouts
all of the like meat like chicken
products including the chicken nuggets
chicken pieces grilled chicken and
barbecue chicken are made with authentic
flavors
high quality ingredients and our non-gmo
and gluten and dairy free both like meat
and fries plant-based products make easy
swaps and family favorite recipes from
your
barbecue chicken sandwiches to your
pasta dishes
my final tip is to spring clean your
desserts by satisfying sweet cravings
with less added sugar for chocolate
lovers the new candy bites by quest are
delicious option
each candy bite is bite-sized and packed
with rich
chocolatey flavor gooey caramel and
nutty crunch with less than one gram of
sugar
and one gram of net carbs so you can
satisfy your sweet tooth
at home or on the go you can find the
quest candy bites at questnutrition.com
and in many retailers including target
now i hope you enjoyed all of my tips
and recipes you can find them at my
website nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas
and nutrition tips daily